(hip-hop beat music)
- Bye.
- [Babin] Questions?
- Yeah.
- [Babin] Did that Instagram thing?
- Yeah, what up, blog, vlog.
Here, the PureWow team.
Some meetings in Boston,
which is an interesting feeling,
because I love Boston humans,
but I hate the Patriots so much,
that even when I'm here,
I feel like I'm in more
of a warrior mindset.
Like I'm ready to fight,
verbally and physically
at all times, with anybody.
Anyway, Babin did a good
job because all the meetings
we're doing today are
things that we cannot film.
And so, I'll probably give him a good rant
at the airport, but to fill out the vlog,
I guess you did something?
And got some questions.
- [Babin] Yeah.
- So we're gonna do some Q and A here.
- [Babin] Q and A.
- Which I think is a good
format for us in general,
'cause Q and A is like....
Ask Gary V. is like few and far between.
I think once, even a week,
if we look at my schedule,
just doing Q and A is a good format.
Anyway, vlog, I hope you like this format.
Go ahead, Bobby Babin.
- [Babin] First off, how do you balance--
- You don't have the person's name?
- [Babin] I screenshotted--
- You're a bad guy.
- [Babin] I'm not.
- See, you're selfish.
But you know how fun it
would be for that person
to have their name, okay.
Fair enough, go ahead.
- [Babin] How do you
balance clouds in the dirt
and which do you focus on more, and why?
- So, to define to everybody
how I define clouds and dirt.
Clouds to me is like the
why, the strategy, the macro,
the big thinking, the big
picture, the operating system
of, like, how you do things.
And then the dirt is having the humility
to go to these meetings, to actually....
I post all my Instagram photos.
The doing, the humility, ego, humility.
Strategy, execution, clouds and dirt.
The way I balance it is they're
both important at all times.
I can swing back and forth to them.
I can literally go from
a meeting where....
Like the call I had on the way out
to our first meeting here today.
Purell was with Vayner Media's see suite
about a restructuring of how we handle
all our business, super meta.
And they literally hung
up and I posted something
on Instagram and wrote all the copy
as we were walking into our last meeting.
To me, I balance them by doing
whichever one is needed at the time.
And so, I don't think
about it as balancing it.
I think about it as time allocation.
Like, what should I be doing with my time?
And I think that you made a joke,
we did a shoot for a client and we debated
on the phone for 10 minutes where the
should be located, for that.
I think that's being in the middle, right?
I think pandering to the
way companies do things.
We just had a meeting where they're like,
oh, that was provocative.
Us, as the gallery media group
and all the other things we do.
Us doing what every other publishing does,
company does, is not a good idea.
That's the middle.
That's not gonna get
you to the next place.
And so for me, I'm just in the mindset of,
either doing humble, dirty work, like,
the reason I am the best
strategist in social media,
out there, I really believe this,
is because I do both.
I both sit at the top of the media company
that really does it at scale,
for the biggest companies in the world.
But at the same token,
there's very few humans
that put out 100 fuckin'
40 pieces of content
by hand, a week and reads the--
I mean, I literally just replied to Kyle
in my comments who,
and I'm gonna show you,
'cause I don't think you guys believe me,
when I do these fuckin' rants.
I literally just replied
to Kyle one second
before Babin's like,
"Let's do this video."
Literally, what I was doing,
one second before then was
replying to...
literally, like, literally hearted
Kyle's comment of, "I'm digging
"the recent pics and quotes, man."
Right?
Many people watching here
would argue that my time
at this point of my career
of reading Kyle's comment,
and hearting it, in that minute,
was a bad use of my time.
I think the dirt is the
reason why I come up
with such good clouds.
Being in the trenches, drives my strategy.
I live in reality and practicality,
not in thesis or ideology,
or reading headlines,
or reading about people doing marketing.
So, I don't balance it.
I just do whatever is
needed at that second.
It's back to macro/micro, micro speed.
I'm just always doing something.
Right, Bobby?
That is the big breakthrough
everybody on the team says.
There's just every second is....
And so the reason I can
do something every second
is that I don't watch a YouTube video,
or stand by the water cooler and talk
about the Rockets game for 10 minutes,
is 'cause I always value the dirt.
And so, in that half a
second that I had right now,
in the transition of
the call that I just had
about a macro veiner ex-strategy, right?
The second transition I
had before I started doing
a macro thing, like the vlog,
was hearting fucking Kyle's two cents
on my last Instagram post.
Clouds and dirt.
- [Babin] Yeah, we should do more Q and A.
(both laughing)
- [Babin] What do you
do to recharge yourself
when you feel physically exhausted?
- Sleep.
Physically?
- [Babin] Yeah.
- Sleep.
Sleep matters.
- [Babin] Rolling still?
- I'm always rolling.
But you can ask something, we won't put it
in the vlog if it's sensitive information.
I think Ryan just wants more vlog time.
- At ryanharwood_27@gmail.com.
- But on our--
- [Ryan] I'm gonna set it up.
- Yup, cool.
- [Ryan] I'm gonna have Lisa there,
just to scoop up.
- Yup.
- [Babin] - Question, Joe?
- Joe.
- [Babin] How in your 20's were you able
to blow off parties and girls
and leisure stuff and
just focus on your career?
- [Ryan] Oh I can answer this one.
- Nobody invited him anywhere.
(all laughing)
- No girls wanted to associate with him.
Have you seen a picture of his license?
Go on ryanharwood_27's
Instagram right now--
- I think it's a cute photo.
I think that's cute.
- That's fair, Ryan was
much cooler than me.
You know, as a long island club promoter,
he, no question, had
more of that opportunity.
I think it comes down to,
for me, it was easy 'cause I was obsessed.
I was obsessed with my
career, and I continued to be.
I think the reason I can play
in the dirt is my obsession.
So, I just think it's priorities.
You know, most people are just gonna be
average human beings,
and wanna live through,
the party life in their 20s,
and be Goldman Sachs
banker, and play tennis.
You know, that's most people, the average.
The people that are not remembered.
And then, some of the--
- [Ryan] What?
(all laugh)
- And some people, are going for all time.
And I was going for all time,
and I was willing to
give up the thing that
most people want during that time.
I just, I was...
You know, recently I've remembered,
I had a burning desire,
to pay back my parents
for being the best parents.
I really wanted to build my
family business for my parents.
A lot more than I've recalled.
As I'm going through all these motions,
I was passionate, like, just obsessed
with building my family business for them
because they had put me
on so much, emotionally.
You know, people are always saying--
When people like to
harass me, they're like,
"Easy for you to say, you
were given a liquor store."
I wasn't, I built a business for my family
and left with no economics
because emotionally,
my parents perfectly parented me
which is now been the
foundation of all my success.
- [Babin] Alright, last
one now from Chris.
- Chris.
- [Babin] If you decide to go all in,
and you get burned by a business partner,
do you cut all ties, or just accept
how you were played and maneuvered?
- Well I think the way
that question was asked,
it sounds like there
was a prior relationship
with that person, so if
that person's a friend,
you know, these are
very personal questions.
Here's what I would say.
I am utterly unemotional when it comes
to business because that just--
You know, the game of
business is business is real.
Like, you can handle it any way you want.
My default is always
to be the bigger person
because I think that's
the ultimate leverage.
So, you know, even with
the people I compete with,
which I compete with feverishly,
even people that have--
I mean look, there was
a gentleman who stole
hundreds of thousands
of dollars worth of wine
from Wine Library, he went to jail.
Like hundreds of thousands.
And I've forgiven him, and interacted
with him through the years.
I think grudges are poison and are anchors
that hold you down, so for me,
I think it's about chalking
it up to experience,
I think if you truly were played,
if it's not your perceived
notion that you were played,
if every one of us saw
the situation and said,
"Oh yeah, you were played."
You know, I chalk it up to,
"You were played, be the bigger person."
You know, and I would actually have,
I would also feel sad--
To me, anybody who does
something dishonest
is coming from a place of weakness.
I kinda feel bad for the
person that played me.
So, you know, yeah...
I just...
I think the higher road
is strategically right.
You go faster, you're
not looking backwards.
When you're looking backwards,
people are passing you by, and so,
yeah, I'd feel bad for them.
- [Ryan] Nice.
- Cool.
Yo.
That Q and A fire, I think
we just hacked a new system,
leave in the comments if you like this
new vlog, ask Gary V. concept,
I think it's gonna fuckin' work.
(lo-fi beat music)